and you risk your life every moment now
you don't have a choice
the only thing you can choose is what
you're risking it for hey youtubers it's
charlie happy Halloween
this week on The Walking Dead Carol and
Tyreese were the runaway stars and we
learned that you cannot get upset
everyone has a job to do let's talk
about our favorite moments and then I'll
do a review the episode let's talk about
Tyreese first so we pick up with the
burn bodies from last episode and right
away it is crazytown population Rick and
Tyreese it was really fun to watch them
just lose it all over each other
obviously I think we kind of expected
Tyreese to lose it since he was kind of
on the edge of sanity anyway she was
really the person helping him keep it
together so once she died I knew she was
gonna hit the fan eventually and what
about that moment when he was sitting on
the road and the charger by himself who
else thought that he was just gonna sit
there and let the wave of zombies just
wash over him obviously he just
basically went into animal mode after
that but I think it's kind of implied
that he's basically been bitten or been
compromised in some way so I wouldn't be
surprised if he forces the group to kill
him in the next episode don't you think
he just basically wants to die at this
point just when he was sitting in the
car he's just ready for it to all be
over it's just gotten too crazy for him
and how crazy is it that Daryl is now
the voice of reason he was a in
season 1 after he thought that his
brother had been left behind and now in
Rick and Tyreese lose it he's basically
the one to grab Ricketts they get ahold
of yourself the actor that plays Daryl
said something funny he basically said
that Daryl actually never wanted to be a
leader and you kind of get that sense
from him but he's kind of thrust into
this position too I'm actually really
excited about Daryl's character this
season what about him and me Shaun -
when they were getting ready to go on
their road trip did he just get the
sense that they are definitely going to
hook up sometime this season if he/she
was gonna hook up with anyone it's
definitely gonna be Daryl but like I
said at the beginning of the video carol
is the other real star of this episode
he basically is just as crazy as Tyreese
she just hides it a little bit better
whenever Rick was investigating that
burn scene and the music kind of swelled
up and this really creepy way you just
knew something awful was gonna happen
and then he put his hand on the door and
kind of realized that it was actually a
small hand at that point I thought it
was either Karl or Carol and honestly
it's just a little too hardcore for Karl
at this point he is growing up though he
totally got that awesome hero shot in
the woods with the Hat on when he had
his gun out you definitely know that
he's going to have a really big hero
moment this season so I'm really looking
forward to that too
when Rick finally confronts Carol at the
end of the episode I thought that was
one of the greatest reveals to the
episode she just is totally nonchalant
about it like yeah I burned him I did
like his question though is there
anything that you wouldn't do for the
people in there and she's no there's
nothing I wouldn't do it was really at
that moment that it kind of confirmed
that she was the one that did it but
Rick asked her anyway did you burn those
bodies yes of course they didn't they
just walks away obviously she's trying
to do the right thing but I really like
the way the show kind of puts morality
into this really big gray area they
basically have to do whatever they need
to do to survive everyone has a job to
do nobody can get upset Herschel was
like the real moral touchstone for this
episode he's like a man of total faith
he's let's the Zen master of cellblock 8
right now he just goes in there and then
once the doctor coughs blood all over
him he takes that bandana off and he
basically just let's all pretenses go
honestly I think what's gonna end up
happening is that Herschel's medicine
will say that about half the people and
the other half will just die but now for
my review overall I loved the episode I
totally give it an a-minus
I love the way the show is maintaining
its pacing really really well the
intensity is just slowly building that
scene where Daryl's group actually runs
into the walkers for the first time they
just go for miles and miles and they're
obviously all heading towards the prison
so they'll get there eventually honestly
I think by the end of this season the
prison will basically be like an island
of people in a wall-to-wall sea of
walkers the shore under Glen Mazzara did
say that this season would feature more
walkers literally physical walkers on
the show than in any season previously I
really love that they keep coming to the
fact that they have to do whatever they
have to do to survive like sometimes
that means not saving people that can't
be saved so I think that's gonna happen
in the next episode or two whenever this
flu finally runs its course I don't
think the flu is going to last all
season I think that storyline is gonna
wrap up in a couple episodes remember we
only really have till next episode
before their run at a time
Sasha is character when she was talking
to Tyreese basically said we can make it
till tomorrow that's enough time for
them to get back with medicine we might
be okay and Hershel actually said that
most of the people don't even have 12
hours let me know what your favorite
moments were and what do you think is
going to happen with the group in
cellblock a I'm really pulling for Glen
I really don't want Glen to die I'm so
hoping that Herschel's medicine helps
them next week actually features a
medicine run with Rick
because remember Dale's group that was
going to get medicine is stuck in the
woods so hopefully Rick will be able to
bring some medicine back in time be sure
to subscribe to get my next week's video
be posting that right after episode of
four airs as always if there's anything
that you thought was really important in
the episode that I didn't mention in the
video please write it in the comments
and we'll discuss if I as always if you
really want to help me out please like
and share this video while we wait for
more Walking Dead next week you can
click here to watch all my other Walking
Dead videos and you can click here to
watch my special Game of Thrones
Halloween video thank you so much for
watching happy Halloween high fives guys
see you tomorrow